hello belief nation I started a mentor
me series to try to hang around people
who've done a lot more than us and
hopefully by spending a little bit more
time with them some of how they think
their values their beliefs their
mindsets their attitudes seeps into us
to help us become the best version of
ourselves so today we're going to learn
from Grant Cardone and some of his best
motivation mentor me grain rule number
nine is my personal favorite and I'd
love to know which one you guys like the
best and as always guys as they're
watching if you hear something that
really resonates with you please leave
it down the comments below put quotes
around it so other people can be
inspired as well and when you write it
down it's much more likely to stick with
yourself as well enjoy
[Music]
you
that's not a normal state that's lazy
okay that's not normal to be putting
your head down on a table to not be
moving snap and pop do not be adding
wood to your fire look lazy as I wrote
in this recent article that was read by
almost four million people with I think
as of today fourteen thousand likes and
just as many dislikes even people
Rachael and angry maybe you're getting
like that right now about my article
that lazy it's a new entitlement look
just see if this describes you or anyone
you know I only do enough I make as
little as possible I save as little as
possible
I invest as well as possible I learn as
little as possible in hey I work as
little as possible and when my five days
are over with each week I have to I must
take Saturdays and Sundays off I'm
entitled to it these are the policies of
the lazy and they are ruining our
country they're ruining anyone that
operates with them okay normal a normal
state is not lazy a lazy person is
actually educated encouraged
acknowledged and it's allowed lazy is an
allowed state in organizations so if
used to anybody in your group in your
organization in your family this lazy
hey knock it out man they don't work you
end up with too little money not enough
love not enough work and not enough
customers lazy is a failed policy and
I'm here to wake you up about it look if
you want to be in business for yourself
and free you must learn to dominate you
cannot compete ok how many were trained
this competition is a healthy thing that
message was not being delivered to
entrepreneurs that message was being
delivered to consumers
there was somebody saying look the more
more oil companies we have the better
because it's good for the customer right
the more technology companies we have is
not just Microsoft the better for the
customer and in 2 billion inventions and
you know improvements and products comes
from competition but if you're the one
playing the game
you want to dominate the field so look
here's the deal I might be wrong and
what I say
okay I might be wrong in the things I do
in my life and the business that I
started my family's told me not to start
every business that I've been involved
in every one of them every one of them
was a risk everyone on my hand to take a
chance I remember my mom used to tell me
I wouldn't do that if I were you I
wouldn't do that if I were you I
wouldn't do that if I were you I might
mommy
you wouldn't do anything you wouldn't do
anything except be the mother a great
mother to five children
my mother was an entrepreneur she didn't
have my dreams just because she's my mom
doesn't mean she dreams like me would
you agree okay
my mom was wrong about everything she
told me not today love my mom to death
okay unbelievable friend of mine she was
wrong I needed to do those things okay
Steve Jobs needed to build this phone
would you agree did he help a lot of
people did he make some money while he
was doing it 119 billion dollars in five
years in the bank cash I'm not talking
about probably I'm talking about in the
in done in the bank sitting there okay
brings a great product to the
marketplace domination or competition
total domination coca-cola competition
or domination total domination okay
Exxon total domination you see what I'm
saying you want to be in a dominating
point okay so what we got to do is we
got to get you thinking we got to get
you thinking like the dominators think
how do they act how does Warren Buffett
act what does Warren Buffett do with
this time all the time those are the
people I study today I don't study the
people that I went to school with the
teachers I went to school with I don't
even study my own family members okay
I'm looking for people that are way up
here that I could say hey what are they
doing because they're doing it right if
you know what day it is you are not busy
enough I recently heard this week
oh it's Monday man it's so hard to get
started on a Monday I'm like dude how do
you even know it's Monday I don't know
what day it is on Wednesday we hear it's
hump back day we're halfway there so
it's Friday and it's like oh thank God
it's Friday or follow Friday or like -
how do you people know what day it is
you're not busy enough you
need to be so freaking busy that you
don't know what time it is you don't
know if it's before lunch after lunch
before dinner after dinner come on
you've had those productive days
remember the day when you were so
productive you you literally work
through lunch and dinner and you looked
up at 7 o'clock you should have been
home an hour ago and you're like dude I
haven't had lunch or dinner you know why
because that day you were eating the
marketplace you were consuming the
marketplace because you were active
productive hitting it slamming creative
and completely committed look that's
where you need to be today look I don't
know what Monday Wednesday or Friday are
I don't know about Saturdays and Sundays
I know this create tremendous amounts of
activity so much activity that you lose
track of time your success is not going
to come from watching TV or looking at a
calendar your success is going to come
from activity from being busy from being
obsessed from being like so into it that
you don't know about oh my gosh the
Monday morning blues or Wednesday hump
back or Friday what Friday what whatever
ok get busy hello the biggest struggle
man was just getting around other people
that would say I could do it I mean
that's the biggest struggle just you get
around one guy says yeah you can do it
and then you talk to him tomorrow and
he's like nowadays freakin he can't do
this you know there's so few people
telling you to do it you know what there
is a lot of save your money
protect yourself conserve don't spin
don't take risk taking risk is the new
way to be risk adverse so we're the
biggest struggle for me was my family
man the people closest to me was the
biggest trouble every time I went out to
do another deal everybody told me you
don't need to do that man
the only person that was encouraging me
was my twin brother because I would see
how he was doing it dude he was making
his swings and so every time I'd get
around other people so I'll tell you a
little trick I did on weekends I would
always go see homes I couldn't afford
that has always inspired me I would go
look I would go drive neighborhoods
literally I've done this my entire life
until I finally got
to the point where they wouldn't even
let me in the neighborhood there's
neighborhoods in Miami do you can't even
go see you can don't want to let you in
the gates most of you can get in if you
know some mometrix' so the point that
show Vitas writing on the board right
now is you got fuel in your tank
it wants to be accelerated on and then
you got somebody in the backseat saying
hey be careful nobody likes a backseat
driver okay
so they're sitting there they're putting
they're putting mental pressure on the
brakes when you're trying to accelerate
I use every one of the news channels if
you'll see me on TV doing news one day
okay I don't I don't watch this I make
news see the shift you see the slight
shift don't watch the news decide when
you leave here today to make the news
right you don't read the newspaper you
write newspaper articles you don't read
books ya read them but learn to write
them and you know you don't need to take
for it you don't need to spend a
lifetime right in the book this was
three hours okay we still 40,000 copies
of this one book and it was
self-published has never ever ever been
in a bookstore a guy writes me says man
you got misspelled words all in that
book I'm like yeah yeah what so what
where are they 123 128 134 165 120 I'm
not yeah yeah and bad grammar too I'm
like yeah what you pointed I know what's
your point man why you keep telling me
that he's right cuz man you got
misspelled worked in a book it's a
best-seller
[Music]
okay so it it ain't that's written okay
you know what I'm not in this work just
so any nobody under think that's a cuss
word the word hooked it up in the
dictionary means a complain or a whine
or an excuse maker I wear a little ban
on my pen here on my wrist here it's a
little black band and it says champions
dominate and on the other side don't be
a little bit yeah that's right because I
don't need it I need to get rid of the
whiners the excuse makers oh my god is
to market its the market of my job your
prices holy inventory
okay now I'm let's go there's too much
inventory now too little inventory you
human beings have so many excuses that
is unbelievable you know why because you
watch the news too much because you've
agreed to receive news not make news the
thing is not to just be positive
not even to offer this no negativity
policy that I talked about the way to
avoid a negative and distracting people
man is to vibrate at a rate so fast okay
that you're out in front of them once I
got a speeding ticket actually here in
Miami and the police officer says whoa
what why you speeding why you in such a
hurry I'm like dude I'm trying to stay
away from the crazies okay if I can just
get ahead of everybody else I'm not
distracted by anybody but guys like you
and your job is to stop me but the truth
is their job is to stop me distract me
and cause me to turn around and and and
stop my mission see so I got my ticket
and moved on and went to the head of the
pack again see this what I'm telling you
man look if you want to not be bogged
down by negative distracted people you
need to take responsibility that you're
slowing down enough to get caught up by
this magnetic charge of distractive and
negative people do you need to vibrate
so fast that these people are
distracting other people not to get way
ahead of the crowd gets so busy that
nobody's going to Jack with you man
because you're filling up your pipeline
you're full you're busy and you don't
have to stuff sticking to you over and
over every almost every seminar I go to
somebody will walk up to me and say dude
how do you handle Bernal and my reply is
fast and simple I don't believe in
burnout that's right I don't believe in
burnout now I know if you're
experiencing that the exhaustion that is
associated with this idea of burnout
that nobody can prove by the way it just
seems impossible to you that burnout
doesn't exist but I'm telling you listen
to me
burnout is not real it's made up take a
step back for just a second while I try
to sell you on this idea and try to
remember a time when you are on fire on
fire lit up excited about being an
entrepreneur see that's gone right yeah
grant I'm burnt out that's what I'm
telling you no no go back to the time
when you were lit up on fire you
couldn't sleep at night you didn't need
to eat okay all you needed was the idea
of a future you had for this dream this
idea this business whatever see at that
time you were goal driven you're the
possibilities were enormous they fed you
you were mission driven see it's when
the missions missing it's when the
mission goes away that a person starts
to experience being tapped out or burned
out or exhausted at least this is my
experience look when I'm not tapped
fully into my future my goals the
potential the possibilities I don't care
what the job is whether it was me when I
was working at McDonald's in a country
club
I was working on a rig down in in the
Gulf of Mexico or whether I was writing
my first book look when your goals
aren't big enough when you're no longer
sold on your vision your purpose your
mission the symptoms of losing interest
what many call burned out burn out or
experienced anytime you stop reaching
for massive success the next thing you
start settling in getting comfortable
this and settle to settle oh I just want
to settle down they want you just but
once you just decide to to be
to hate your life every day see that's
when you start having problems when you
start selling
that's why comfort and complacency are
the entrepreneurs worst enemy in fact I
would tell you this the comfort and
complacency are everybody's worst enemy
the only time I've ever gotten in
trouble in my life was when I was bored
complacent when I was settling Who Wants
average who wants average nobody wants
it okay nobody no matter where you're at
in life you don't want average but we're
surrounded by average people everyday
average ideas average products average
advertising only those that have given
up on greatness would settle for average
hey I want to talk to you today about
success success duty obligation
responsibility if you approach in any
other way which most people are most
people think well I'll be successful if
the economy works I'll be successful if
something happens I'll be successful if
I win the lottery ticket look you're not
going to be successful if you don't
demand it if you literally don't stake a
claim to and say this is mine it's
important you're not going to have it I
promise you I know I'm telling you from
experience I spent the first 25 years of
my life like like I spectator watching
other people get successful and then
wondering why was it success is your
duty it is your responsibility so your
obligation and your responsibility is
important you know I mean there's so
many mistakes salespeople make I think
you need to get down to like the main
ones but you're not selling the solution
I mean that even before that though I
would say Corinne is the biggest mistake
people are not excited they're not alive
they're not they're not showing interest
in the cycle and they lose interest I
was in Barcelona recently and I was
looking at a watch and the cycle didn't
didn't close I could have bought the
watch I was qualified to buy the watch
I'm the one that walked myself in the
shop on my vacation to look at the watch
I know exactly the watch I was looking
for and when I left my wife said what
could he have done to close the sale I
said well he could have kept a life in
the cycle he could have kept the cycle
open so what I mean by that is look if
you're not interested if you don't
the cycle can be closed it will not
close so the number one mistake I think
salespeople managers and the store makes
is they assume a closed can't be had
that day I go into every cycle every
sale cycle with every prospect every
phone call every no matter how complex
the sale is or how simple it is with the
belief that I can sell that product that
day this time now a message to you this
week right now is not the time to stop
you can't stop I wake up this morning
I'm like my god man what's going on
what's happening to the world the place
is coming what you know it's a scary
place to live in and I'm like what are
you doing you're stopping right now now
it's not the time to stop or worry or or
back up or become apathetic now is the
time to start again
that's right again it's like I got to
start over and over I got to continue
every day like you do to improve
yourself improve your skills improve
your game every day start over now is
not the time to start or back up a
retreat or get lost in all the problems
look you got to assume right now that
you can do way more way more than you're
doing ask yourself this question asked
myself this probably five times a week
and what is my potential is my potential
greater than what I'm delivering that
regardless of what people think about my
achievements or lack of achievements
whatever the case is I've been on both
ends in this thing where people were
disappointed with me but early on in my
life and also today what people are like
and how do you get so much done neither
one of those should be where you're
living it should be what is my potential
what is your potential have you
fulfilled that potential can you do more
can you make more contacts this is the
model that we need to provide for one
another for our kids for our parents for
everyone in our community look don't
look for others to do this they're not
look around you and what you see is
average everywhere averages become an
epidemic you don't have people living up
to their potential
your people doing almost nothing people
retreating backing up people that are
lazy people that have checked out people
that are waiting for handouts and crumbs
and think that will give them security
look now is the time to start again your
security your family's security your
future is left in your hands your
destiny is yours not someone elses
nobody else can do this for you nobody
else can do it for me it's your job in
my time now is the time now is the time
to start now it's the time to start
again
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed I'd love to know what
did you take from this video that you're
going to immediately apply to your life
or to your business what was the most
important lesson that you learned
please leave it down in the comments
below I'm super curious to find out I
also want to give a quick shout out to
Simon Stanley's Simon thank you so much
for picking up a copy of my book your
one word and making that awesome review
on your YouTube channel
I really really appreciate the support
and I'm glad you enjoyed the book what's
good guys so I'm standing here and in
this video I'm doing a video review of
your one-word by Evan Carmichael so
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon
well when I was 16 I started using drugs
and when I was 25 I was using drugs 15
times a day and I tried to quit for nine
years everyday for nine years so so then
I went to a treatment center because my
mom's like hey don't even come around
everybody gave up on it like everybody
this isn't this isn't some kind of
pulling hard story this is like people
hated me okay
and the worst part of it is I did I
hated me so I wasn't that I was broke
and I didn't have a job and all that all
the bad stuff but did the feeling that I
had about myself you know was just awful
so I went to the treatment center you
know and got off the drugs quickly quit
using drugs for 25 days and they told me
I had to leave because the insurance was
over what a scam that is and and the
counselor dude I don't even remember his
name but he told me on the way out he's
like hey man let me tell you something I
don't know if you've ever gone to one of
these 12 steps kind of deals but you go
in and you do like it's huge
introspection on yourself and then you
got to share with the group all your
stuff so I'm telling these guys that I
want to be rich and I think I'm James
Bond I'm not I'm the reincarnation of
James Bond and you know I'm gonna you're
right look dude I'm gonna be famous man
and people are going to see me I'm gonna
do all this well every time you do that
over there they're like no no give up on
the ego give up on grandiosity you're
not going to be rich if you just don't
use trucks one day at a time then you
need to be happy the guy told me on the
way out of the place he's like look if
you don't give up all that you'll never
make it and I walked out of there and
said dude I'm gonna get rich I'm gonna
get rich I'm gonna get famous and
because I had a good I just couldn't
live a life of just not doing drugs
because I don't think drugs with my
problem you know it was just a symptom
of something else that when arrived
and so when I went back I took that
addictive that you know that 15 times a
day and not trying to use drugs and I
took that energy and I threw it in work
and you know how I work dude I'm a
maniac you know so so I took it and I
basically people sort of tell me y'all
you just replace one addiction with with
another addiction and I'm like yeah
that's exactly what I did I replace one
addiction with a nuzzle and now now I
get addicted to the good things in my
life the negativity is just negative and
there's no money in it there's no future
and being negative where is the solution
you know I can't do that we can't do
that that can't happen this is wrong
that's wrong oh my gosh taxes are too
high taxes are due dude it's negative it
is negative it is negative look there's
so much abundance and negativity that by
itself tells you what there's no value
in it I hear a lot of people talk about
one purpose the one thing you know one
thing has never filled me up whether it
was one friend one drug whatever dude
what one doesn't work for me one wife is
good that's all I need I love my kids
one family you know but but I've always
needed something else you know I need I
need something else to fill me up you
know and and it was up I'm 35 years old
and these people are like dude when are
you ever going to be satisfied I heard
that a lot when's enough enough you know
why can't you just enjoy what you have
what's right looks like something was
wrong with me and I bought it I bought
those ideas I talked about this in the
book about feeding feeding the beast and
starving starving fear and I kept
hearing about this you know well you're
never going to be satisfied nothing
fills you up and that's why you're so
disappointed and people would say things
like don't have high expectations you
know Sam Walton said the only way to
live a life is with high expectations
the only way to achieve anything is with
high expectations but something happened
in American between 1980 and
thousand where where everybody started
doing this intersection feel your
feelings
what's the chicks name over it Steve
Carlos's place does the coach over there
uh Harry no no the one that's the one
that says go go inside what what was
their name and I used to watch that I
said is needed because it's just naughty
lamp ladies like like I've done it I've
done so much introspection that I
couldn't do anything
I had become immobilized my purposes I
mean what's wrong with somebody that
wants to do another thing you know that
bit look I am NOT filled up by one
person my wife cannot fill me up two
kids can't make me feel full because I
think if people are obsessed with a lot
of purposes and that's why people are
dissatisfied and I my goal is that this
book gives people permission to be to
not be so introspective but to actually
become obsessed with dreams again with
possibilities with the idea that you
could be a husband a father a community
leader a church leader you could
actually talk about politics you could
get rich you could write books you could
find time to do all that and not even
worry about balance because the
accession of each one of those things
would actually fill you up to have a
life that was that was naturally
balanced